orders that states namely New York New
Jersey and Pennsylvania
issued mandating nursing home residents
admit coveted positive patients back
from the hospital
throughout my medical career I treated
many very serious infections
usually very vulnerable patients with
serious comorbidities
the very idea of placing infected
contagious patients in a facility with
uninfected vulnerable patients troubles
me deeply
especially when other more viable
options were available
these must admit orders led to the
deaths of tens of thousands of elderly
Americans
we hope this hearing is step one to
providing accountability for the
thousands of American families seeking
answers
it quickly became evident that covid-19
was especially dangerous for the elderly
there was a thousand fold higher risk of
poor outcomes specifically
hospitalization and death for older
people relative to younger populations
it also became clear that individuals
with pre-existing comorbidities were at
an increased risk
therefore it was critically important
that the public health response
prioritized these high-risk populations
to reduce their risk of infection
this was understood by the centers for
Medicaid and Medicare services and the
Centers for Disease Control and
prevention who put forth guidance
consistent with these priorities
on March 13 2020 CMS issued guidance
that specifically directed nursing homes
to only accept covid-19 positive
patients if they were able to do so
safely and only if the nursing homes
could properly follow CDC isolation and
quarantine guidance
this science-based guidance aimed to
keep covid-19 out of nursing homes as
much as possible
it intended to prevent the at-risk
elderly population from exposure to a
highly transmissible virus and it was
designed to avoid infections
hospitalizations and deaths among the
most vulnerable population
while many states followed these
guidelines states such as New York New
Jersey and Pennsylvania impose mandates
directly contrary to this guidance
these states instead implemented must
admit orders that effectively required
nursing homes and long-term care
facilities to admit covid-19 positive
patients regardless of the home's
ability to protect their patients
these orders unjustifiably exposed
America's most vulnerable to covid-19
with predictable and deadly consequences
prior to issuing New York's must admit
order then Governor Andrew Cuomo said
quote for nursing homes this could be
like fire through dry grass end quote
he was seemingly quite aware of the
risks
according to the most recent available
data New York suffered more than fifteen
thousand nursing home deaths as a result
of covet 19.
Pennsylvania suffered more than twelve
thousand five hundred nursing home
deaths and New Jersey suffered more than
nine thousand nursing home deaths
of that more than 200 veterans at
state-run veterans homes in New Jersey
died as a result of covid-19 including
89 at a single Veterans Home in Paramus
New Jersey in what has been described as
a horror show
in Andover New Jersey authorities
discovered that a nursing home was
storing 17 bodies in a makeshift morgue
these were fathers mothers uncles aunts
brothers sisters
grandpas and grandmas
they deserve better
from our Public Health authorities and
from our politicians
they and their families were failed by
these deadly must admit orders
unfortunately
it's clear that decision making by
politicians not science or scientists
was responsible for these misguided
decisions
science never supported must admit
orders
science did not support rejecting the
federal government's help
Trump Administration sent the United
States naval ship comfort and
transformed the Javits Center to address
capacity issues at New York City
hospitals however Governor Cuomo failed
to use these facilities
at the expense of overwhelmed Hospital
Systems why
why did he fail to take advantage of the
resources offered
science certainly did not lead State
officials to fraudulently conceal and
cover up the number of nursing home
deaths in their respective States
we learned that Governor Cuomo knew that
the must admit order was wreaking havoc
on nursing homes throughout New York
and so his administration froze the
state's nursing home death's data
in an investigative report on covid-19
nursing home policies New York State
Attorney General Leticia James found
that the Cuomo Administration under
reported the number of covid-19 deaths
by approximately 50 percent
was this done by Design
to not only avoid accountability from
the Department of Justice
but to escape political accountability
from the American people
my father used to say to me I don't care
what you did wrong
but if you lie to me
you are in much more trouble
finally science did not support
threatening retaliation against one's
political enemies
Governor Cuomo
threatened to destroy New York State
assemblyman Ron Kim whose uncle died in
a New York nursing home for not
participating in this seemingly
fraudulent scheme to conceal the true
nursing home data
unlike Governor Cuomo's kova 19 response
this selects subcommittee was not
created to score political points
nor to sell books
and we owe it to the victims families to
hold those who implemented these deadly
deadly mandates accountable
and the public officials who engaged in
political cover-ups and manipulated
mortality rates for political expediency
they must answer to the American people
we're not here to Monday Morning
Quarterback or to negate the difficulty
of decision making during during an
unprecedented pandemic
but once science is clear
those who made wrong decisions must be
held accountable
we are holding this hearing today to
look back to help prepare for a future
pandemic
to determine what went wrong to
recommend how to do it better
to ensure that future health policy
decisions are based on scientific facts
not political calculations
and I suspect today
we'll talk about how changes have been
made and suggest better ways going
forward
that is appreciated
however we must identify wrongdoing and
hold people accountable otherwise it
will happen again
and victims and their families will
never feel whole again
I look forward to a strong on topic
discussion today
I would now like to recognize ranking
member Ruiz for the purpose of making an
opening statement
thank you Mr chairman first let me Begin
by thanking you miss Dean and messiah's
for being here today I'm deeply sorry
for your losses
okay any death due to covid-19 is a
tragedy and my heart is with you and the
families of the 200 000 residents and
staff of long-term care facilities
across the country who perish during the
pandemic
three years ago a novel deadly highly
transmissible Airborne virus to cold
and while we knew little about covid-19
and and its long-term impacts on human
health at the time we did know that our
nation's seniors were amongst our most
vulnerable when it comes to suffering
severe illness and death
so as covid-19 swept the country and the
federal response to the virus faltered
under President Trump's states were
forced to Grapple with an unfamiliar
Public Health threat
and yes policy missteps were made
on March 4th 2020 the centers for
Medicare and Medicaid services issued
guidance permitting nursing homes to
admit and readmit covid-19 positive
patients but only
if the nursing home could do so safely
following protocols to prevent
Transmissions among residents and staff
however in an attempt to relieve
Hospital strain in a time of Crisis
States like New York went beyond this
guidance requiring nursing homes to
reopen their doors to covet positive
patients
with must admit orders regardless of
safety and capacity to follow guidance
and protocols and as in a physician
I
disagree
with it
now as kova 19 hospitalizations and
deaths have decreased exponentially
thanks to the availability of vaccines
and improved Therapeutics we must build
better policies that will save lives and
prevent harm in the event of another
pandemics
as members of this select subcommittee
we must develop forward-looking policies
that promote transparency in data and
strengthen Protections in nursing homes
to mitigate current and future threats
so we do need to take a look back at our
nursing homes where were we when the
pandemic started where were we during
the pandemic with our nursing homes
preparedness
we must also look to rehabilitate
nursing home systems weakened by the
previous administration's efforts to
roll back regulations that established
guard rails for quality of care and
Staffing levels leaving those facilities
under resourced and underprepared to
combat a deadly virus
for example in July 2019 seven months
before the pandemic took hold the Trump
administration's proposed deregulation
of on-site infection control
resulted in facilities cutting Corners
assigning already overworked nurses to
take on responsibilities intended for
infection controlled specialists
at the same time the previous
administration proposed loosening
standards to review patient care needs
reduced consequences for nursing home
regulation violators and lifted
protections for residents and families
to take legal action in the event
of mistreatment
what's more the Trump administration's
prolonged failure to secure adequate PPE
and testing kits led to increased
Transmission in both nursing homes
and their surrounding communities
for example a 2021 NIH study found that
nursing homes in the same communities
that experienced High rates of infection
saw extreme shortages in Rapid covid-19
testing
the deregulation or removal of
protections of the nursing home industry
coupled with shortages in kova 19 tests
and PPE were also missteps and
contributed to devastatingly High rates
of nursing home deaths throughout the
country as high as nearly one out of
every 50 residents at the peak of the
pandemic according to AARP
so
when the next pandemic rolls around
we must ensure that our nation's nursing
homes and long-term care facilities are
fully equipped to respond to and reduce
transmission of a deadly novel virus
this means identifying real solutions
now
that will prevent harm and save lives in
the future we cannot allow overwhelmed
Health Care staff to be left behind and
we must adequately equip them with the
resources they need to provide quality
care and services to their patients
under presidents Biden's leadership we
have taken meaningful steps towards this
goal this includes reinstating
enforcement of federal nursing home
standards
improving inspection
and strengthening our health care
Workforce
and let's not forget successfully and
efficiently delivering life-saving
vaccines to our most vulnerable
populations significantly reducing the
death rate among nursing home residents
now there is still much more work to do
so let's make sure we're sufficiently
investing in skilled nursing home staff
and infection control measures keeping
in place protections and let's hold to
account those Bad actors in the nursing
home industry who skirted regulations
and fueled the alarming death toll we
experienced during the height of the
pandemic
we can all agree that we can and must do
better and I am confident that if we
work together we can identify common
sense bipartisan solutions that put
people over politics save lives and
right the wrongs that cause so much
suffering in this pandemic thank you and
I yield back
thank you
our Witnesses today are Miss Janice Dean
this Dean joined Fox News channel in
January 2004 where she currently serves
as a senior meteorologist for the
network both of her in-laws passed in
New York nursing homes during the
pandemic
we express our sympathies to you
Mr Bill Hammond
Mr Hammond is a senior fellow for health
policy at the Empire Center in New York
before joining the Empire Center Mr
Hammond spent almost three decades in
journalism
Miss Vivian zias and zayas is a
co-founder of voices of seniors she is a
mom of six she unfortunately lost her
mother in New York nursing home and has
since become an advocate again we
express our sympathies
Dr David Grabowski Dr grabrowski is a
professor of Health policy at Harvard
Medical School where he studies
long-term care and post-acute care
pursuant to committee on oversight and
accountability accountability rule 9g
the witnesses will please stand and
raise their right hands
do you solemnly swear our affirm that
the testimony that you are about to give
is the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth so help you God
may be seated
thank you let the record show that the
witnesses all answered in the
affirmative
the select subcommittee certainly
appreciates you all for being here today
and we know this is difficult
and we look forward to your testimony
let me remind the witnesses that we have
read your written statements and they
will appear in full in the hearing
record
please limit your oral statements to
five minutes
as a reminder please press the button on
the microphone in front of you so that
it is on and the members can hear you
when you begin to speak the light in
front of you will turn green
after four minutes the light will turn
yellow
when the red light comes on your five
minutes has expired and we would ask
that you please wrap up
I now recognize Miss Dean to give an
opening statement
good morning chairman winstrup ranking
member Ruiz and the members of the
select subcommittee on the coronavirus
pandemic thank you for inviting me to
testify today on the horrific
preventable tragedy that unfolded in
Elder Care Facilities in the spring of
2020 that took the lives of over 16 000
seniors in New York state including my
husband's parents
Mickey and Dean Newman were married for
almost 60 years they lived in the same
four-story walk up in Brooklyn for
decades where they raised three children
Donna Michael and Sean Mickey was in the
U.S Air Force and joined the fire
department of the city of New York
serving for 23 years in engine company
323 in Brooklyn
Dee was a devoted wife a mother and a
grandmother and worked at the local
dentist office part-time
she never missed a birthday or an
anniversary and there are still days
where my husband has the urge to call
her on his way home from work which was
part of his daily routine
before the pandemic Mickey had a series
of health issues he was in a nursing
home for Rehab to get into better shape
before he could join his wife Dee in an
assisted living residence
and then came covet 19.
Sean got a call in the late morning at
the end of March 2020 and was told that
his dad was not doing well
he had a fever his breathing was labored
three hours later he was dead
Sean had to break the news on the phone
to his mom in lockdown that her husband
died it was the hardest thing he's ever
had to do
my husband saw his mom once in early
April after that to bring her some
flowers
he could not pass the front desk he saw
her in the lobby for only one to two
minutes standing 10 feet away with a
mask on
he told her he loved her and she started
to cry before he left
he would never see her again
a few days later Dee's Health went
downhill she was moved to the hospital
tested immediately and diagnosed with
covet 19.
the last time Sean spoke to his mother
she told him her throat was raw she had
trouble breathing
despite her ill health her final words
were to ask him to buy Easter presents
for her grandkids and to please write
her name on the card
a nurse called us the next day to tell
us she was in and out of Consciousness
the next day she died
our grief and our confusion turned to
anger in the days and weeks afterward
when we learned how Elder Care Homes
were turned into death traps
over nine thousand coveted positive
patients were piled into facilities for
46 days and no one told the families
three years later
we still don't know why
our former disgrace Governor Andrew
Cuomo said more than once that covet
inside of nursing homes would spread
like fire through dry grass he knew the
elderly were the most susceptible and
yet he let it happen he lit the match
and he set the fire
all of us here today would like to know
the origins of where the March 25th
order came from and why nursing homes
were prohibited to test incoming
patients it's also worth mentioning that
while Care Homes could not have access
to tests Andrew Cuomo's friends and
family were secretly able to secure
tests and use State resources
the other question we have never had
answered is why weren't the facilities
provided by the federal government
government ever used there were
thousands of empty beds in the Jacob
Javits Center the USS Comfort ship and
other several ad hoc hospitals while
nursing homes were packed with sick sick
people
it was recently revealed that a U.S Navy
Admiral on board the Comfort ship quote
begged the kumomo administration to send
patients to the nearly empty hospital
ship docked on the Hudson River during
the height of the pandemic but instead
of helping quote his pleas were met with
politics and paranoia
many couldn't see their loved ones
before they died or have wakes or
funerals instead of doing his job to
protect our families the former disgrace
governor was busy getting his staff to
write a 5.1 million dollar book with
various Awards including an Emmy and
blaming everything and everyone else for
the mistakes that he made
he likes to say our advocacy is
political but not one grieving family I
have met here has told me who they vote
for
all we've ever wanted was to have a fair
bipartisan investigation into why so
many of our elderly died painfully and
alone
the death toll in our senior living
facility number 11th and Hurricane
Katrina combined there have been
hearings and accountability for both
those tragic events why is this any
different
and as much as I am grateful to be
invited here today having hearings alone
will not bring Justice
we need to learn from this tragedy
to turn our grief into purpose and find
out what happened to our parents and our
grandparents
who trusted us and our leaders to
protect them
thank you
thank you Miss Dean I now recognize Mr
Hammond to give an opening statement
thank you good morning thanks for the
opportunity to testify
um we're here today to talk about
a mistake I don't know how you want to
characterize it but it came to symbolize
the worst aspects of
the response in New York and even
Nationwide
um we're obviously it's about an order
that compelled nursing homes to accept
coveted positive patients
um even viewed in the best light this
was an act of desperation the state had
just gone into lockdown the hospitals
were filling up some projections
indicated they might become overwhelmed
and so State officials in effect were
trying to avert a crisis in the
hospitals by creating a crisis in a
nursing homes
where they knew residents were acutely
vulnerable
this episode needs to be closely
investigated for a number of reasons as
we've just heard thousands of families
have a legitimate reason to wonder
whether their loved one was died as a
result of a government action
um but also we need to understand how it
occurred so that we can make sure it
doesn't happen again so that future
officials will have better options in
front of them in a similar situation or
maybe just to prevent that similar
situation from happening
during the 46 days this policy was in
effect 9 000 patients transferred from
hospitals to nursing homes most of them
were new admissions most of them were
not going back to a nursing home where
they had been before
these transfers were probably not the
only source and I'm certainly not the
only source of coveted nursing homes
but they made a bad situation worse
an analysis by my colleague in Ian
Kingsbury and I found a statistically
significant correlation between the
number of patients transferred and
higher mortality rates in the nursing
homes that accepted them
according to our analysis the policy was
associated with several hundred and
possibly more than a thousand additional
resident deaths
the directive tragically also appears to
have been unnecessary although hospitals
were filling up they never
became as overwhelmed as some of the
projections indicated and never the
system never fully ran out of beds and
these alternative facilities such as the
Javits Center and the U.S naval ship
remained largely empty
this was part of a chain of policy
failures that led to the situation
like most States New York could not
adequately prepared for the pandemic it
didn't have an action plan for example
for what to do when hospitals filled up
during an outbreak of infectious disease
it didn't have an adequate stockpile of
PPE
it didn't have the tools to know when
the outbreak had started which was
probably in early February and so all of
that slowed down the state's response
and led to a situation in late March
where the situation appeared to be out
of control and officials really had no
idea how bad it was and how much worse
it could get and that's the context in
which the Cuomo Administration made this
decision
they compounded things once once the
decision became known to the public
which took a few weeks and once it
became the subject of some criticism and
controversy they compounded their
original Mistake by engaging in a
cover-up they pulled the directive off
the web so that it wasn't available for
the public to read
they misstated how it had worked they
misstated
how it related to federal policy they
made it sound like it was completely
consistent to federal policy when it
differed in key respects in particular
their policy did not talk about the
importance of infection control and
didn't talk about and I mean as as the
chairman mentioned they didn't talk
about
how important it was to say for example
isolate these patients in separate wings
or floors
also they said that this really was
optional as it sounded imperative but it
was actually optional because of a
regulation the state had that said
nursing homes should never accept a
patient that they can't handle
it turns out that the governor had
suspended that exact regulation seven
days before he issued the order
um
but finally and maybe more worst of all
in this cover-up they understated the
number of deaths when they finally came
clean with the full data which was in
response to a lawsuit brought by my
organization
the number was closer to 15 000 which is
six thousand more than they had
previously acknowledged
um this this pandemic in addition to the
tragic deaths in nursing homes it cost
millions of lives it cost trillions of
dollars we need to be Excavating every
mistake like this mistake and
understanding how they played together
and preparing for the next virus which
we know is coming and the time to do
that is not when the next virus arrives
a time to do it is now thank you
thank you Mr Hammond I now recognize
Messiahs to give an opening statement
chairman winstrup ranking member Ruiz
and the members of this committee thank
you for the invitation to testify before
the select committee on the coronavirus
pandemic
I wanted to firstly thank God and the
members of this committee for these five
minutes that I have this morning to
share my family's story which Echoes
that of thousands of others three years
ago or so goes by really quickly except
when you're grieving for many it's been
over
1141 days of seeking answers into why
our mothers and fathers or other loved
ones met their fate in the manner they
did
we often think of nursing homes as
places where people or old people go to
Dime however this isn't always the case
there are many patients in short-term
Rehabilitation such as young people
recovering from gunshot wounds or car
accident or other debilitating illnesses
or otherwise healthy individuals
recovering from routine surgeries or
minor injuries my mother Anna Martinez a
physically mentally and emotionally
strong woman in her 70s developed
arthritis it was aggressive and hampered
her quality of life following doctor's
orders we in our in our due diligence we
she underwent replacement knee
replacement surgery her first surgery
she was scared but she was reassured
that it was a routine and she would
quickly recover after some physical
therapy
after the surgery we were full of
expectation that we would see our mother
in her kitchen again cooking her amazing
dishes
our mother was in the midst of recovery
at home post-surgery when she developed
a cyst after treatment at her local
hospital she was sent to a nearby
nursing home rehab facility to receive
inpatient Physical Therapy it was
expected that she would gain strength
and return home soon a minor wound LED
my mom down a path into a nursing home
from which she would never return
our daily visits came to her to to the
nursing home came to an abrupt end in
the march of 2020 when the facility
called to notify us that all visitation
would be suspended for approximately two
weeks we never saw our beautiful mother
again she was dead shortly after gasping
for air alone confused and scared
without her daughters who were her
translators and caregivers she could not
tell us anything was wrong or that she
was exposed to covid-19 because she was
also kept in the dark like many other
families nursing homes kept them in the
dark as well never telling us that they
were admitting covet positive patients
in the insistence at the insistence of
Governor Cuomo we also had no idea that
the nursing home failed to have proper
policies in place to deal with
contagious disease our initial inquiries
to our local legislators requesting an
investigation into the factors that
contributed to the death of our loved
ones were met with roadblocks vitriol
and partisan accusations that was
extremely troubling since my mother a
Puerto Rican woman who along with most
of our family were lifelong Democrats
how could those recovering from surgery
or immuno and the or the
immunocompromised be locked in a
facility with a deadly contagion
especially in the Care Homes riddled
with complaints and historical
violations of not adequate adequately
following infectious disease protocols
in addition to the lockdown the lockdown
policies they allowed a perfect
environment for neglect and abuse to run
amok out of sight of family and
caregivers if these weren't all painful
enough out of nowhere the governor of
New York used his powers to give nursing
homes illegal immunity for their
negligence allowing facilities to get
away with causing needless death due to
poor care
we only slowly became aware of the
behind the scenes politics that the
nursing home owners were the governor's
largest donors
soon after the death of our mother and
in search for answers we found a
community of families who share their
tragic stories by the hundreds we formed
voices for seniors to give seniors and
their long-term care residents a voice
our daughters other daughters and sons
heartbroken by the untimely deaths of
their parents such as the alvino family
who lost her beloved father and husband
Daniel to covet in a rehab facility
after neck surgery or John Daly a loved
husband and father and grandfather who
no one helped him eat and debilitated
prior to succumbing to covet or Robert
Nieves a veteran whose last words were
I'm afraid
or Carmela abandonzo who found who was
found dead in her bed during a routine
nursing call and countless others that
my heart cannot bear to recount being an
advocate for the elderly and others who
reside in long-term care facility has
been a feat more difficult than we could
have ever imagined especially when
everything is a partisan football
we won't let our loved ones die in vain
and we won't let this be swept under the
rug due to politics
when will we see the elderly Community
elevated to a position of dignity and
respect that they most certainly deserve
will we need will we see a deep and
thorough investigation into all the
factors that led to this tragedy both
the ones who lit the match and those
that allowed it to burn we truly thank
you for holding this hearing this
morning and we truly and sincerely hope
that no stone will be left unturned to
get down to every cause and effect that
led to the pain and Devastation
inflicted on so many now I will address
the Hispanic Community really briefly
Latina que pelions
thank you again
foreign
to give an opening statement thank you
chairman wenstrip ranking member Ruiz
and distinguished members of the house
like subcommittee thank you for the
opportunity to testify today on this
important topic I'm here today speaking
in my capacity as a professor of Health
Care policy at Harvard Medical School
who has studied nursing home care for 25
years this is actually my third time
testifying to this subcommittee on the
issue of nursing home and covet the
first time was back on June 11 2020. as
part of my remarks that day I said and I
quote a key point I wish to emphasize is
that much of the impact of coveted
nursing homes could have been avoided
with increased Federal leadership
resources and attention rather than
prioritizing the safety of the 1.3
million individuals that live in nursing
homes and the staff that care for them
the federal government has chosen to
push the logistics and costs off to the
states and the nursing homes by failing
to invest in testing personal protective
equipment and the workforce the federal
government has allowed a problem that
started in a single Nursing Home in
Kirkland Washington to grow into a
national crisis end of quote three years
later I stand by that statement
completely I'm not letting nursing home
local or state leaders off the hook they
deserve blame too yet more than any
other entity our federal government
failed our nursing home residents and
their caregivers back in 2020 at the
start of the pandemic looking back covid
completely devastated nursing homes in
the U.S to date there have been over 1.6
million coveted cases among residents
leading to roughly 176 thousand coveted
related fatalities
over 3 200 nursing home staff members
have died from covid making nursing home
worker the most dangerous job in America
not surprisingly both resident census
and staff employment levels are still
down by seven to nine percent relative
to their pre-pandemic levels
a key question in directing policy
resources is determining what factors
were associated with covid-19 outbreaks
in nursing homes in a systematic review
of 36 peer-reviewed studies our research
team concluded that covet outbreaks were
largely a function of where you were
located versus who you were as a
facility
this does not suggest there was nothing
that could have been done to prevent
covet outbreaks rather it suggests that
federal policy makers needed to adopt a
system-level approach to address this
problem it is not too late there are
several short-run and long-run reforms
that can support nursing home residents
and their caregivers in the short term I
am supportive of the reforms put forward
by the administration in terms of
increasing ownership and financial
transparency in minimum Staffing
standards however I would categorize
these reforms as necessary but not
sufficient we also need to continue to
ensure that more nursing home residents
and staff receive their booster doses
currently less than one-fourth of
nursing home staff are up to date with
their vaccinations
moving forward we need transformative
system level reforms I recently served
on a national academies of Sciences
engineering and Medicine committee which
offered a road map forward for these
longer term reforms
the national academies report provides a
strategy to move toward a federal
long-term care benefit that provides
adequate Financial coverage of
comprehensive nursing home care
Medicaid currently plays a dominant role
as the default player of nursing home
care but eligibility is limited by
income and acid tests and is constantly
subject to state budget constraints
too many nursing home corporations use
complex ownership structures to siphon
dollars away from Resident care
to increase Financial transparency and
accountability by nursing homes policy
makers must collect audit and make
available detailed facility level data
on the finances operations and ownership
of all nursing homes in real time in a
readily usable database
a more effective and responsive system
of quality assurance is also needed for
nursing homes the survey process often
fails to identify serious care problems
fully correct and prevent recurring
problems and investigate complaints in a
timely manner
moreover CMS which ultimately determines
the facility's eligibility to
participate in the program does not
provide sufficient oversight of or
transparency in the survey process
as such state survey agencies must be
given adequate resources for increasing
oversight of state survey performance
and evaluating strategies to improve
quality assurance activities
in summary we have an opportunity today
to begin to address problems that we
have ignored for far too long I look
forward to working with the members of
this committee on this effort thank you
thank you I now recognize myself for
questions
uh Dr Grabowski I do want to say thank
you for your making suggestions of how
to improve the situation going forward
those will be taken into consideration
uh for our report along with other
opinions as well I I will say one thing
about
um you made it sound like mandatory
boosting when I think that getting a
booster should be based on the personal
personal health
let me give you an example
I
was vaccinated Pfizer both doses later
got coveted I didn't know till I
couldn't smell garlic salt right I was
told I needed a booster to go to Germany
I couldn't get my T cells checked but I
got my unbodies checked strong number
was 40. mine was 821.
we do run the risk of hyper immune
responses so I think we have to inject
personal medicine into each person as we
decide whether someone it should be
boosted or not that's just another
medical opinion but certainly one that
we can discuss further but I just
thought I would say that as I as I heard
you you say that and I appreciate
suggestions being made but Dr Grabowski
was it known that kova 19 was
particularly dangerous to the elderly by
March of 2020.
uh yes the the first major outbreak was
in Kirkland Washington nursing home
facility so we immediately recognized
how dangerous this could be for older
adults we've answered my next question
with the first outbreak
um should that have informed decisions
regarding protecting nursing homes
absolutely but a few States particularly
New York New Jersey Pennsylvania ignored
this early evidence and directed nursing
homes to admit potentially coveted
positive patients regardless of the
home's ability to treat its patient we
heard that from Mr Hammond as well today
as a physician this is contrary to what
we are taught
and so why is it a bad idea to
intentionally introduce an infectious
agent into a vulnerable population
so nursing homes with older adults frail
living in close quarters if covid starts
in a nursing home it's going to spread
and it's very hard to contain once once
you have an outbreak within a facility
we saw that in Massachusetts where I
live New York all over the country
you know someone who treat a lot of
infections I was always grateful when we
were able to do for example home IV
therapy for infections because it kept
people away from a vulnerable population
uh Mr Hammond did Governor Cuomo say
these were necessary to prevent
overcrowding at hospitals
I mean eventually he said that it wasn't
he did it wasn't discussed at one of his
briefings at the time it wasn't
announced in any way the nursing homes
didn't know it was coming until they
received a memo
and was Governor Cuomo given
alternatives
uh well
they had the they he himself had put a
lot of effort into building alternative
overflow facilities he received help
from the federal government in building
the facility at the Javits Center and he
and the uh the the Navy ship was also
brought in
so in your opinion were those facilities
used to the extent that they could have
been based on what you were able to
investigate and see no I mean that's
it's those facilities were used very
little at all during the during even
during the worst of the crisis I think
it turned out that it was harder than
officials realized
to transfer patients once the facility
was available you still have to figure
out who who should be transferred and
how they should be transferred for
example the the Navy ship when it first
arrived it said we can't take any
coveted patients that's a huge obstacle
in the situation that was presented so
they eventually got that changed but
even then you had logistical obstacles
to moving patients those are the kind of
things those logistical obstacles are
the kind of things we need to be
thinking through now
before we're in this similar situation
yeah I would agree you're either taking
all coveted patients or you're taking no
covet patients and allowing more room in
the hospitals for non-coveted patients
or for coveted patients the Comfort only
treated 182 patients in the Javits only
treated 1095 vice admiral Mike Dumont
pleaded with the Cuomo Administration to
send patients this was the comfort's
mission to alleviate concerns related to
overcrowding hospitals one way or
another nonetheless the Cuomo
Administration failed to utilize this
support Miss Dean do you think politics
was responsible for these Federal
resources being wasted
Governor Cuomo liked to blame politics
at every turn that that was the reason
why people were talking about nursing
homes asking him the questions all the
time
he had the resources and he failed to
use them
and I think if we uncover
where that March 25th order came from
who wrote it
I have my suspicions I think it has to
do with Hospital lobbyists I think
there's a money Trail
why were nursing homes the only option
so even though Governor Cuomo likes to
blame politics and Fox News and the
weather and mother nature he never
self-reflected and that's something that
he should have done
have you you've been a fierce Advocate
obviously since the beginning on this
issue how has your Governor Governor
Cuomo treated you
Governor Cuomo
well
attacks belittlement I believe his
um
one of his aides said well Janice Dean
she's not a reliable source on anything
except the weather
um even though I had two close family
members die in separate Elder Care
Facilities
I'm aware of I haven't seen them of
texts that were exchanged between Andrew
Cuomo's brother and the administration
calling me interesting names that I
don't want to repeat today but there was
no
sympathy there was never a gesture of a
phone call no condolence cards I don't
think he really met with any families he
just decided to write a a book talking
about how great a leader he was
Messiahs
initially we actually tried to reach out
to Governor Cuomo and
in his press conferences interestingly
he kept saying that we were being
political and I think as janistan said
you know there were seniors and
residents who died who were of every
political affiliation and when you're
grieving you're not thinking of politics
you're thinking of answers you're
thinking of getting down to the bottom
of why this happened one so that we can
have Justice and two so it doesn't
happen again so we were sad saddened
when he continued to the end to make it
a political issue and then in the
beginning when we're crying and baffled
at the order and wondering like many
families did not know that while we were
locked on the outside there was covet
positive patients bringing back through
the back door and only after our
belongings of our loved ones were handed
to us either in trash bags or in boxes
with our parents name and our questions
start to Bubble that's when we realized
sadly that this terrible thing was
happening and it just compounded the
pain it's it's unbelievable how raw the
pain is even today
Dr Grabowski going forward to the next
pandemic
as you look back were these orders a
mistake
yeah I said it at the time and I said in
my testimony this this was a mistake
Miss Dean
one of the biggest mistakes this country
has ever done
Messiahs
seniors are in vulnerable positions
every single day this is not just a
one-time issue
unfortunately in the path that we have
both Miss Dean and I we have realized
that there's horror stories of All Sorts
not just during a pandemic but that the
pandemic actually opened up a door to
really find out what is going on in
these facilities these facilities do not
have proper ppes or equipment or your
training every day of the year
it is just compounded when you're
putting an exorbitant amount of sick
people in these facilities and then
they're not being separated the the even
the staff is working with kovid
and on the eve of my mother when I the
last I heard her voice which she sounded
like a a gargoyle
I was told she was going home they were
going to send my mother with an oxygen
tank with a contagious disease without
telling me
and when we found out that she was going
home and she couldn't even answer the
phone when I was calling her to just she
was excited to go home and when I called
her she didn't answer I became so
worried and what they were telling me
we're going to send her home at an
oxygen tank and I said how if she can't
breathe how and we had no testing we had
no idea she had coveted we thought she
had a bad cold
and they said we're just going to send
her home they kept playing games they
supposedly offered her an iPad to talk
to me and I was so frightened that what
I was going to say if my mother had been
sent home with an ambulet service
directly to her apartment with an oxygen
tank my mother would have died alone
because I had no idea what was going on
thank you very much uh I I would say
that from the very beginning
for this subcommittee and this is this
is a new subcommittee
this is an after action review
for lessons to be learned
and to have a better path forward
so that we are prepared so that maybe we
can predict and protect ourselves and
maybe even prevent a pandemic
so I appreciate all of you being here
today for just that
now I would like to recognize the
ranking member for questions
thank you let me Begin by reiterating my
condolences for you miss Dean and
messiah's and for every family who lost
a loved one to kova 19. every life lost
to the pandemic is a tragedy and I'm
deeply sorry for what you have
experienced
compassion is a human trait that we need
more of in our words our policy and our
Behavior towards one another
to regain our Humanity
muchas gracias
is factors
[Music]
de nada
in the early days of the pandemic or
knowledge of how this deadly novel virus
spread in our tools to protect the
vulnerable from it were extremely
Limited
as a nation we grappled with how to
prevent covid-19 from infiltrating our
nursing homes and our nursing homes and
the Trump administration were not as
successful as we needed them to be at
that time
but the tide of the pandemic turned for
Nations nursing home residents with the
arrival of the kova 19 vaccine and the
rollout of the most effective and
efficient vaccination campaign in
America's history according to AARP data
at the conclusion of the Trump
Administration nearly two of every 100
nursing home residents in the United
States was dying of kova 19.
six months later in July 2021 following
the Biden administration's massive
mobilization of resources to get shots
in arms the covid-19 mortality rate for
nursing home residents fell dramatically
to .03 per 100 residents
Dr Grabowski how did America's covid-19
vaccination campaign turn the tide of
the pandemic for nursing home residents
it was an absolute Game Changer prior to
the vaccine rollout
if if you had a covet outbreak within a
nursing home you were going to see lots
of fatalities you had the AARP statistic
I'll give you a different one for every
five residents that got coveted prior to
the vaccine one of those led to a covid
related fatality after the vaccine
that's actually been for every 25 cases
confirmed cases only one of those
individuals one of those residents is
dying so the vaccine has been an amazing
success and today actually this calendar
year that's down to one out of every 50.
so we've made tremendous progress It's
been a real game changer and how did
vaccines reduce the threat of the
broader Community spread and
transmission which your research shows
drove nursing home infections and
fatality during the first year of the
pandemic you know one one of the studies
that we conducted was to look at what is
the impact of having kind of Greater
vaccination among staff staff live in
the community as vaccination rates went
up in the community as vaccination rates
went up among staff what impact did that
have on Resident fatalities and sure
enough there's positive externalities to
getting staff vaccinated it doesn't just
protect our staff it actually protects
our residents we saw resident fatalities
go down how about the overall community
in that the nursing homes existed in
absolutely that was the pathway prior to
the vaccine that they were cases came
from the community and if you bring it
down in the community you're bringing it
down in the nursing home okay a crucial
component of the Biden administration's
effort to protect nursing home residents
was the implementation of Common Sense
requirements for health care workers to
get the kova 19 vaccine you and your
colleagues have conducted your own
research evaluating the importance of
these requirements for health care
workers what has your research shown
about the role of vaccine requirements
for health care workers in reducing
cases and deaths among nursing home
residents and how are these policies
associated with live saved once again
the the rollout of the federal rollout
of the vaccine was incredibly productive
but it was productive for residents
staff were still lagging and so the
mandates really brought vaccination
rates up for staff we found that saved
lives the higher rate of vaccination
through the mandates led to fewer
coveted related fatalities for residents
okay so one critical aspect of this
Mission
and a top priority of mine as a wrecking
member is to ensure that this select
subcommittee remains focused on
developing these forward-looking policy
solutions to prevent and prepare for
future Public Health crisis
um and uh and one critical aspect uh is
ensuring that we are working decisively
to reduce the threat that future novel
viruses posed to vulnerable populations
in nursing homes and other long-term
care facilities uh what steps should
Congress and the federal government take
to better prepare for the threat future
pandemics pose to our nation's nursing
home residents right I've called this a
crisis on top of a crisis so we we both
need to develop policies to deal with
the short-term crisis the next pandemic
but we also need to get our nursing home
house in order in terms of those
long-term policies such as how we pay
nursing homes how we regulate them
quality and ownership transparency so
there's kind of bigger reforms and then
there's these smaller reforms like
investing in personal protective
equipment and testing and all the
infection control infrastructure that's
necessary to really protect our
residents under President Biden's
leadership and thanks to the investments
in life-saving vaccines funded by the
Democratic American Rescue plan that
President Biden signed we have made
tremendous progress in protecting our
nation's seniors from the Coronavirus
going forward we must learn from the
challenges and missteps of the early
pandemic response or lack thereof to
ensure that we are making our nursing
home safer
getting ahead of future public crisis
make sure that we don't roll back
protections make sure that we respond
quickly with urgency for testing and
ppes make sure that we increase care
standards and that we have transparency
and oversight on the care standards in
nursing homes in order to save lives
and I must say that
there's a lot of hearings happening at
the same time and there's one where
there's actual votes happening so you're
going to see some of us come back and
forth and we mean known disrespect
especially to the witnesses when we have
to just get up and go and so that's I
think that's why there's a scant members
here so please excuse our absences and
and running back and forth thank you I
yield back
thank you I thank the ranking member for
pointing out the challenges that we're
facing here today with a variety of
committees taking place at the same time
pursuant to committee rule 9C the chair
May recognize members for extended
question time I therefore Grant Ms
mellitaka seven minutes if she needs it
with equal time being granted to a
member of the minority at the ranking
member's discretion Ms malitakis you're
now recognized thank you Mr chairman
I want to thank the witnesses for being
here
my condolences to those who had lost
loved ones wrongfully taken away from
them
I'm going to highlight
timeline and the decisions that were
made by the Cuomo hokel Administration
New York that ultimately led to over
fifteen thousand of our seniors dying in
nursing homes on March 13 2020 the CDC
and CMS released guidance stressing that
a covid-19 positive nursing home
resident must be quarantined and
properly treated the guidance directly
forbids
nursing homes from accepting patients
they were unable to properly treat on
March 23rd the CDC released updated
guidelines detailing when and how to
transfer and discharge hospitalized
patients it encouraged testing
requirements of two negative tests or 72
hours after the resolution of symptoms
on March 24th I know those of us from
New York remember this very vividly the
governor during his Daily Press
Conference said my mother is not
Expendable your mother is not Expendable
and we are not going to accept the
premise that human life is disposable
and we're not going to put a dollar
figure on human life
despite those nice words the very next
day on March 25th the governor issued
his lethal directive mandating nursing
homes regardless of ability to provide
care to accept covid-19 positive
patients discharged from hospitals thy
directive prohibited the nursing homes
from testing the patients prior to
admittance and the nursing homes were
not even given the proper PPE to care
for these individuals
this continued even after
in New York City we had Alternatives U.S
Navy Comfort Javits South Beach
Psychiatric Center in my district
this was directly against the CDC and
the CMS guidance and Common Sense
it wasn't until May 10th that the
governor quietly rescinded the March
25th directive
and by the time this dangerous policy
was rescinded almost 50 days later over
10 000 nursing home deaths occurred
including some in 323 facilities that
apparently had reported no
covid-19 infections before receiving
admission or readmission of Hospital
residents who had been diagnosed with
covid-19
as I mentioned they were Alternatives
that Cuomo had even asked for he ordered
some of them to be set up and then he
didn't use them
on April 7th Mike Dumont the vice
admiral of the U.S Navy emailed Melissa
DeRosa Governor Cuomo's top Aid
the email here
pleading for help to get more patients
into the Javits and the U.S Navy ship
comfort as they only had 83 and 37
patients respective respectively
DeRosa then sends an email to the
executive chamber staff which to us
seems like she was just trying to cover
herself
and then in a recent interview Cuomo
said that by the time the U.S Navy
Comfort ship arrived in early April they
no longer needed the bets which is
completely false in fact over 7 000
coveted positive patients were
transferred from two nursing homes from
the time the ship arrived to when the
governor's directive was rescinded on
May 10th 7 000.
after his March 25th directive started
receipt started receiving more and more
attention during his daily briefings
Cuomo and an array of high-ranking
government officials including his top
aides DeRosa and the health commissioner
Howard Zucker who by the way shockingly
I think to everyone in this room now
serves he's been elevated to serve as
President Biden's deputy director of
global Health at the CDC
well
they began to participate in a cover-up
their event their efforts would result
in the true number of nursing home
fatalities being suppressed for months
and I've got another chart which will
show you
the difference it wasn't until the
Attorney General accused Cuomo and his
cohorts of Under reporting and the
Empire Center which we thank Mr Hammond
for being here today winning a court
order releasing the complete data so my
first question Mr Hammond your
organization did a tremendous Public
Service fighting to obtain this
information and complete the complete
data how was the information manipulated
based on your assessment
so
starting in April the state was
releasing
counts not just of how many people had
died generally but also a separate
number for nursing homes and then a few
weeks later they modified how they were
releasing that to take out
the cohort of residents who had died
after transferred to a hospital so when
they got sick they got sick enough that
they needed hospital care they were
probably put in an ambulance taken to a
hospital and then they died in the
hospital
and the state stopped including those
people it had it had data on how many of
those people there were but it it backed
them out of its daily reports and why
would they do this in your opinion
I believe they were trying to make the
situation in nursing homes look less bad
than it was because it was embarrassing
to them
and because they did not comply with the
CDC guidance and CMS guidance
yeah that was they they were probably
aware
because of the order that had been
issued that they were going to be blamed
for how bad things got now New York
State's Department of Health released
its Report with the manipulated data on
the fatalities the same day that
Governor Cuomo was meeting about his
book deal do you find that to be a
coincidence or do you think that there
were personal reasons business reasons
ego to the decision
I mean I can't get inside anyone's head
it is a remarkable coincidence that
um
that report you're referring to came out
in early July it was ostensibly a kind
of Quasi scientific analysis of the
situation in nursing homes
it had been Rewritten by the governor's
office and they had pulled out relevant
data and they modified its findings um
so thank you 15 seconds two important
questions in 2021 the governor uh hokel
right the successor and lieutenant
governor to Cuomo promised that she
would be transparent to launch a review
of what happened in the nursing homes
did she fulfill that promise yes or no
not yet okay and my last question was
there a difference in reimbursement
rates between nursing homes hospitals
and the U.S Navy Comfort ship
I don't I don't know the answer to that
okay
well we would like to get the answer to
that question Mr chairman I think that's
a very important question I want to
thank Mr chairman for the time and I
asked for unanimous consent to submit an
op-ed written by Mr Peter arbini who's
here today in The Daily News titled
still looking for answers on covet as
well as testimony from families in my
district who lost loved ones in New
York's nursing homes without objection
thank you I now recognize Miss Dingle
for seven minutes of questions
thank you Mr chairman and ranking member
Ruiz
let me begin I first will tell you I'm
wearing a mask because I got covered
last Thursday the day the public health
warning expired I was fully vaccinated
and boosted my symptoms weren't Pleasant
at this time but I wasn't hospitalized I
tested negative yesterday and today but
I'm wearing the mask following CDC
guidelines because I don't ever want
another person to get coveted if we can
keep it from happening
um and to all of you your stories aren't
horrific
but I've heard them over and over and
they're not unique to New York they're
stories that I started hearing in March
April May at home as well
and they shouldn't have happened period
it's simple we were not ready for the
pandemic let alone we're a nation's
nursing homes ready
and it's troubling because our nation's
seniors are important and they're
deserved and entitled to live their
senior years in dignity and with respect
and no life for the record is Expendable
no life
unfortunately because we weren't ready
the country was not ready and previous
administration's Hazard Federal
responses
and we're pointing a lot of fingers and
we need to understand why what happened
happened so it never happens again
because we did fail this nation we
failed our seniors and we failed their
families
let me talk about Michigan we were hit
very hard there's been the Detroit news
has been running a series of Stories on
this in the last couple of weeks and
among their observations according to
the documents released by the government
the problems largely occurred omitted a
shortage of personal protective
equipment for staff at nursing homes
sometimes hospitals as well as a short
supply of covid-19 tests
Melissa Samuel the president and CEO of
the health care Association of Michigan
said facilities did all they could with
the resources and knowledge available at
the time to provide the best care for
their residents health care workers in
many others stepped up and risked their
lives to care for coed patients as the
world sheltered in place dedicated
exhausted frightened Health Care staff
kept showing up hour after hour day
after day to care for those in need
health care workers and thousands of
others save countless lives during this
unprecedented unimaginable time
but as you all just talked about
too many died
I got an early Glimpse in many of my
cities Riverview Michigan
had a heard from everybody I heard from
the mayor I heard from the fire chief
because of the number of runs he was
having I heard from the relatives of the
Rivergate residents and the health care
workers they repeatedly lodged formal
complaints against the Rivergate
facility in the spring of 2020. for
failing to properly identify and combat
a spike in covid-19 infections
a self-identified registered nurse
estimated that close to 100 patients had
the coronavirus at the 168 resident
Rivergate Terrace and seven workers had
been sent to the hospital according to
an April 9 2020 complaint
the nursing home did not have protection
they didn't have mass they didn't have
gowns or tests to keep them safe I
emptied my garage I'm a hoarder of every
garbage bag I had I went to the schools
and the businesses and the businesses
who had shut their doors and begged for
garbage bags and those nurses or those
attendants wore black garbage bags as
gowns
I took a collection of gloves from every
place I could procure them from and I
worked with the governor's office and
the autos and was making calls to China
begging spending millions of dollars on
PPE equipment to get a chip but had to
find somebody we knew and Trust to go
look and inspect it to make sure it had
quality
and to make matters worse the PPE that
many states were receiving from the
Strategic National Stock stockpile was
expired with dates as far back as 2010.
we need to work on that that's one of
the things this committee must do and
that with in conjunction with the Energy
and Commerce Committee to make sure we
are never ill-prepared as we were and
that this never happens again now I have
a couple of questions Dr gabowski can
you explain how your research found that
troubling correlation between Community
infection rates in nursing home
outbreaks and could you try to do this
quickly because I have a lot of
questions absolutely we looked at a lot
of different factors and the the
strongest predictor of whether or not a
nursing home had coveted was a coveted
outbreak in that Community it's because
the staff were living in that community
and working in the nursing home and that
was the the pathway
if nursing homes had been able to
receive timely and adequate supplies of
PPE and testing Goods kids would that
have had a meaningful impact in terms of
reducing unnecessary infection and death
absolutely our work showed huge
shortages one in five facilities even
during the summer of 2020 uh very few
had access to Rapid testing a really
important study a few weeks ago came out
in the New England Journal of Medicine
suggesting that more access to Rapid
tests led to fewer resident fatalities
the link is very strong
so I want to build in something you
talked about earlier the crisis on top
of the crisis the previous
administration oversaw years of
rollbacks on Federal Regulations related
to the quality of care and infection
prevention in nursing homes this was
severely felt nursing home like someone
in Riverview and I'll tell you another
story in Ann Arbor I had someone call me
and they had 12 patients and nobody
nobody to care for them because the
health care workers were sick and
wouldn't come in nobody do you know what
Panic is when you can't find somebody to
take care of 12 people
the Riverview facility had no personal
protective equipment as of March 20
2020. they didn't have an isolated area
for those with infections and were
asking employees to sign do not disclose
papers one of the complaints alleged I'm
reporting it because it's shameful and
wrong to watch people die because of a
lack of supplies or proper PPE or greed
or proper clean techniques or whatever
the hell went wrong and continues to go
wrong there but it needs to end the
nurse said people are literally dying
every shift in addition persistent and
adequate Staffing levels have been a
challenge in nursing homes for years and
it's worse now we're losing caregivers
as the Baby Boomers age and we now know
that higher levels of Staffing are
associated with the lower probability of
experiencing an outbreak with fewer
deaths Dr Grabowski can you unlaborate
more on your crisis on top of Crisis and
how real it is absolutely we've
under-resourced nursing homes for a long
time we haven't held them accountable in
terms of the quality of care and also
who owns the building and how they're
spending the money and then as you just
suggested there was a trend towards
deregulation of nursing homes under the
prior Administration especially around
infection control the ranking member
outlined some of those steps during his
remarks we were going in the wrong
direction that was the longest ending
crisis when you layered the covid crisis
on top of that it only magnified the
problem thanks thank you Mr chair
I now recognize Ms lesko from Arizona
for five minutes of questions thank you
Mr chairman I have to say I am apps
absolutely outraged over what I heard
today from the witnesses and I'm so
sorry for what has gone on and when we
say it was a mistake that is an
understatement you know this is awful
and so I want to thank you to the
witnesses who are fighting for justice
and for change
I quite frankly laid the deaths of these
thousands of people who died from
covid-19 in New York and other states
that required nursing homes to take in
covid-19 infected people at the feet of
the state officials who decided that
mandate to show this the significance
and the difference between what state
officials policies did let me compare
the differences between New York and
Arizona where I live and Arizona has
lots lots of senior citizens lots of
long-term care facilities so according
to the Atlantic's covid tracking project
New York had 14
450 deaths across across
698 long-term care facilities that is 21
deaths per facility
conversely in Arizona which has a very
large senior population there were two
thousand five hundred five covet deaths
across 1 000 long-term care facilities
that's 2.5 deaths per facility so you
compare 21 deaths per facility in New
York to 2.5 coveted deaths per facility
in Arizona so that's not a federal
problem that's a state problem and so we
have to ask why well unlike New York New
Jersey and Pennsylvania Arizona never
never required nursing homes to admit 19
patients that's the difference that's
the problem and somebody better be held
accountable because this pisses me off
um you can tell I'm I'm impassioned but
I have a question to Mr Hammond do you
think outcomes would have been better in
nursing homes if the focus was on those
populations rather than telling healthy
people not to go to gyms
okay
um
I think both were necessary frankly I
mean you
a lot of people died outside of nursing
homes too and uh and as it's been said
earlier
the there's a connection between the
rate of spread and in the community and
what goes on in nursing homes and so if
if your staff and your family members
are living in the community they're
going to bring it with them into the
nursing home unless precautions are
taken
Miss Dean we have already discussed
Governor Como's disastrous and fatal
policy decisions and the subsequent
cover-up the Department of Justice
declined to pursue an investigation into
Como or the other states that instituted
must admit orders do you believe the
Department of Justice has Good Grounds
for an investigation
100 percent
thank you
Miss Dean could you explain why you
think the Department of Justice is not
investigating
that's an excellent question
and I think the tentacles are deep and
they spread across States and leaders
I think we have to look at the origins
of the March 25th order where it came
from who wrote it
um and I think those simple questions
can lead us into a Direction but
unfortunately I believe that it involves
a lot of people a lot of money a lot of
hospitals and lobbyists and I think
these issues have been in place for a
very long time and the one thing Vivian
said is that the one thing covet did do
is kind of get under the floorboards and
show us how much rot there is already
and so don't let our loved ones die in
vain you know use
this tragedy to do good
for other families going forward
yes it is very curious that there has
not been any investigations or subpoenas
or a former governor on the stand
telling the whole truth and nothing but
the truth
thank you very much and I applaud our
chairman for bringing up this issue it's
so important and it you know somebody
needs to be held accountable this is
outrageous and with that I yield back
thank you I now recognize Dr Berra from
California for five minutes of questions
thank you Mr chairman um
you know a couple couple things um as a
young doctor I did work in Board and
Care facilities and skilled nurse
facilities and everything that you say
in terms of the conditions and so forth
are true
um I do think we should do
um
oversight we should take a look at how
we can protect America's seniors protect
Nursing Home Folks raise those standards
Mr chairman I also think we've pushed
billions of dollars through the American
Rescue plan through cares funding I
think it's worth our doing oversight on
seeing how those dollars have been
utilized and spent much of the ARP
dollars were to actually improve
Services ventilation Etc it's worth
doing oversight so we'd love to work
with you on that
um
I also um yeah
I'm not going to focus on looking
forward I actually want to try to
understand the decisions I'm a
Californian used to be chief medical
officer in Sacramento County and you
know also in my time in Congress have
focused on global Health security
pandemic preparedness so early on was
paying attention to this had the first
sharing in Congress and shared that
hearing on at that time the novel
coronavirus it wasn't lost on any of us
the older
patients older individuals were much
more vulnerable older individuals that
had come morbid conditions were much
more vulnerable you saw that in you know
early data coming out of China but also
in Italy and you know for those of us in
California we saw you know what was
happening in New York
um
yeah early on in February March of
um 2020 we were already making
contingency plans working with our
hospitals
you know for the life of me I can't
understand why anyone would take a
coveted positive patient and put them in
a nursing home where
you know that that's that's medical
malpractice in in my mind and that is a
a decision I can't understand yeah there
were plenty of places we had trailers we
looked at our
um
our college campuses with the dorms and
so forth and lots of discussion of where
you could isolate patients where they
could convalesce until we knew they were
no longer contagious or infectious
um
I Mr Hammond maybe this is a question
for you I know the New York attorney
general looked into what some of that
decision-making process was
um can you share with me
um what the findings were
uh
I'm not necessarily sure what the
Attorney General found but it's been
confirmed that the greater New York
Hospital Association
approached the governor's office and
recommended this policy they were they
were being pressured by the state to
expand their capacity I believe they
were being told they needed to find 50
percent more beds so they were supposed
to convert any available space to
cafeteria what have you
um and they came back to the state and
said you know you could help us if you
could if you would take these patients
who are stable they've recovered they're
stable they're still positive
and if you make the nursing homes take
them from us that will clear some space
so it it was the hospital Association
that recommended it okay and again
just recalling some of the horrific
images that we were watching in
California coming out of New York it's
legitimate to think about how you free
up capacity if you have really acute
patients that you need in the hospital
but again there are alternatives right I
mean it wasn't rocket science to say put
them in the nursing home it was a Javits
Center if it was a hospital ship if it
was as we were thinking about in
Sacramento County getting them into you
know college dorms and providing support
um
are you telling me that nobody is
actually trying to find the answer of
who made those decisions and you know
how those those decisions were made and
I'm not aware of any investigation right
now there there was at one point an
investigation out of the uh eastern
district of New York
okay
um I mean Mr chairman I think it's worth
you know trying to find out you know if
there was a federal investigation the
FBI looked into this or others
um you know we we can't bring back your
loved ones and I'm sorry about that or
any of the loved ones but
it is important to understand how these
decisions were made who made these
decisions
um you know whether there was undue
influence one way or another in those
decisions
um
I'm not a lawyer I'm you know it's not
necessarily about criminal liability Etc
but if we don't actually know the truth
we can't actually help you find closure
and and you know help us move forward so
yeah you know all of us are elected
officials and you know we have
responsibilities and sometimes you know
bad decisions are made but we've got to
try to understand why those decisions
were made and help those informances we
move forward and again I'm sorry about
your losses and chairman would would
love to work with you on trying to
understand
how these decisions were made and who
made the decisions thank you and I yield
back
I'm with you on that Dr Berra
I now recognize Dr Jackson from Texas
for five minutes of questions thank you
Mr chairman
thank you for our witness thank you our
Witnesses for being here today really
appreciate your time uh I just want to
start out by just making some quick
observations at president Trump's
Direction CMS and CDC work together and
acted quickly to put out and
continuously update critical guidance
and recommendations to State and local
governments and long-term care
facilities to assist in mitigating the
spread of covid-19 virus against our
most vulnerable population however a
handful of Governors as we've been
discussing here across the U.S decided
to go against Trump's the Trump
administration's guidance and made
irresponsible politically motivated
decisions to knowingly introduce
coronavirus to nursing home residents
and long-term care patients resulting in
thousands of people dying unnecessarily
while thousands of these these residents
and patients were dying at alarming
rates and family members were prevented
from saying they're goodbyes and
Governor these Governors were
simultaneously being praised and
applauded by left-wing news outlets and
Democrat public officials for how how
they were handling the pandemic in their
state and most importantly for their
refusal to follow issue issue issued
guidance that was had the Trump
administration's stamp on it and it was
a large part of why they did they didn't
do some of what they did in my opinion
as many of my colleagues have pointed
out one of the most detrimental
decisions these Governors made were
forcing nursing homes to accept
admissions of coveted positive
individuals specifically on March 25th
2020 the New York State Health
Department issued a directive that
stated no resident shall be denied
readmission or admission to a nursing
home solely based on a confirm confirmed
or suspected diagnosis of covid-19 and
quote nursing homes are prohibited from
acquiring a hospitalized resident who
has determined medically stable to be
tested from for covid-19 prior to
admission or readmission
end quote uh the New York's the New York
State Department of Health also issued a
report titled factors associated with
nursing home infections and fatalities
in New York state during the covid-19
global Health crisis end quote they they
issued this on July the 6th 2020 and
updated it on July 20 2020 and updated
it again on February 11 2021 even in the
most recently updated version their
report still States and I quote
admission policies were not a
significant factor in nursing home
fatalities end quote and quote the data
do not show a consistent relationship
between this Administration and
increased mortality end quote Mr Hammond
you and your colleague Mr Kingsbury
analyzed the coronavirus deaths in
long-term care facilities using data and
information released by the New York
State Department of Health is that
correct yes
would it be fair to say that the New
York State Department of Health's report
I mean I just mentioned uh contradicts
the findings of your analysis
I would put it the other way around but
yes
did your analysis find any correlation
between the admission of new covid
positive residents and higher death
rates in the nursing homes that received
them yes it did okay thank you
um in Governor Cuomo's book he wrote the
Trump he wrote I quote the Trump forces
had a simple line thousands died in
nursing homes it was true but they
needed to add a conspiracy which was
that they died because of bad State
policy and that Ma and that mandated and
directed the nursing homes to accept
coveted 19 positive people and these
coveted these coveted positive people
were the cause of the spread of the
disease in the nursing home it was a lie
end quote according to the Washington
Post this book isn't is a quote
impressive road map to dealing with a
crisis as serious as the one we have
faced end quote to each of the witnesses
I would like to ask if after hearing all
of the information today would you agree
that Cuomo's book and the official
reviews from the mainstream media that
promoted Cuomo's book as a factual
influential and an example of
outstanding leadership are an example of
disseminating disinformation
Mr listening I'll start with you
I think his book was one of the main
reasons why he hid all of the
information
and I hope someday we can use the words
in that book against him in a court of
law
I would agree with you thank you Mr
Ammon I didn't think the book was was
accurate or well done and and to the
extent people thought it was I think
they were misled
ma'am
he was worried about the
His image
and promoting a book in the middle of a
pandemic not at the end where you can
have more foresight in the middle of a
pandemic while my mother and all these
other seniors were gasping for air and
died alone
I I didn't read uh Governor Cuomo's book
then and I'm not planning on reading it
now do you think the statement I just
read the quote from the book was was it
was disinformation at the time
you know I once again I I I'm not here
to defend him or anything about his book
but I like I I'm not planning to go back
and and revisit what he wrote I I want
to think about nursing home policy going
forward
all right thank you I yield back
I now recognize Mr Garcia from
California for five minutes of questions
uh thank you Mr chairman and I first
want to thank all of you for for being
here I know that
um it's hard particularly for Witnesses
and those that have lost family or
friends and I just want to
um say that I also uh lost both my mom
and my stepfather during the pandemic my
mom was a healthcare worker so I this is
a very serious topic and and um
obviously the issue around nursing homes
is uh it is really tragic and I think
it's something that is a horrific
experience that we went through that was
going on across across the country I
want to make sure also as we review our
actions around covid-19 that we remind
ourselves how uncertain we were at the
very beginning we did not have a lot of
information we were unsure what the
standards were around around washing
hands simple things that we were we were
all panicked about groceries about
shopping but what would be available but
the supply chain there was a lot of
uncertainty we lost 1.3 million
Americans we lost 1300 plus residents
who of my own Community I was the mayor
of Long Beach the entire time we have
our own health department in the city
and so managing all of that particularly
during the time when the spread was
happening in nursing homes was was was
horrific I also would agree that the
governor of New York made some very
serious mistakes I think that's pretty
clear I think to anyone whether
you know whatever side of the aisle I
think we need to learn from those and
and recognize that there's a lot of loss
of life amongst our elderly and our
senior population and that's something
that's very serious and I take it very
seriously but I also want to put in
perspective that in the early days of
the pandemic the Trump Administration I
also believe failed in leadership we had
overwhelmed hospitals we didn't have a
lot of standards in our Nursing Care
Facilities we didn't have enough beds
available in our in our system
so those are things that are true we
also had shortages of PPE and I remember
as mayor having to personally go out and
and get PPE from other places even
outside of our own country to get it to
nursing homes and nursing facilities it
wasn't even always directly given to us
by the by the state or the federal
government so these are these are not
new in 2019 the Trump Administration
also proposed a rule to relax Federal
requirements that nursing homes employ
for on-site infection prevention
Specialists so these are things that
think there were huge mistakes we also I
think need to talk about the fact that
nursing homes in general have not been
well supported even before the pandemic
we know that low wages poor benefits I
talked to numerous workers at our
nursing homes in Long Beach that were
suffering from issues around being
overworked having too many folks to take
to take care of and this was happening
we know not just in New York which we
talked a lot about today but but
nationally now Federal Law requires all
nursing homes to maintain 24 hours of
licensed nursing coverage per day
including a nurse and including a
registered nurse and on-site for eight
hours but does not otherwise specify
additional Staffing requirements just
want to know centers for Medicare and
Medicaid services data showed the
average staff hours for all nursing
homes Nationwide failed to meet Federal
recommended minimums and certainly that
also helped cost uh lives and and the
health of so many so staff shortages
which were in place at the time meant
low quality Care uh folks seeing more
patients and certainly the spread of
infections we could have absolutely been
better prepared the federal government
absolutely under the leadership of
President Trump could have done more to
prepare us and certainly given guidance
to cities and to States and so I think
there's a lot to learn from certainly
from uh from from from places like New
York that were horrific tragedies
happened but also within the
administration at the time I want to
note that low pay and lack of employee
benefits
did cause us issues in the pandemic not
just in nursing homes but also in in our
hospitals I want to um just ask just
quickly Dr Grabowski what does your
research show about the role of the
cohorting orders as opposed to factors
like Community spread and the shortage
of PPE and testing
yeah so our our research really supports
the idea that this was a system-wide
problem nursing homes all over the
country were impacted I think one of the
representatives said Arizona had much
lower rates than New York well Arizona
also had much lower community spread
look at the state where I live in
Warwick Massachusetts relative to New
York if it's in the community it's in
the in the nursing homes we never had
this this mandate in Massachusetts yet
we had a lot of fatalities among our
nursing home residents and a lot of
cases and deaths among our staff too and
briefly how did the widespread shortages
of PPE actually lead to uh to really
dismiss handling we were we were huge
National shortages I I strongly believe
the Trump Administration did not fail in
that respect how did that leave the
community spread on a result impact
nursing homes absolutely so uh PPE is
essential it's our armor against against
covid far too many nursing home staff
lacked adequate PPE once again the data
that we put together during the summer
of 2020 suggested one in five nursing
homes even by the summer was still
reporting a severe PPE thank you sir I
just again want to remind us that
supporting our care workers is really
important moving forward thank you
now recognize Dr Joyce from Pennsylvania
for five minutes of questions thank you
for yielding Mr chairman and thank you
chairman wenstrup and ranking member
Ruiz for holding this hearing today and
thank you to our panels of witnesses for
appearing on this critical topic
in the early days of the coronavirus
pandemic Grievous and critical errors
made by public health officials in New
York New Jersey and in Pennsylvania my
home state had disastrous consequences
for our seniors
and it's clear now that those whose Duty
was to protect our most vulnerable and
high-risk individuals
failed and fell short of the oath to
First Do no harm
on March 13 2020 CMS issued guidance for
nursing homes and long-term care
facilities intending to serve as a
blueprint for individual states to best
prevent and control covid-19 outbreaks
in nursing homes
this was not a directive for nursing
homes to unsafely accept covid positive
patients back into the nursing home
furthermore CMS administrator Seema
Verma said that under quote no
circumstances should a hospital
discharge a patient to a nursing home
that is not prepared to take care of
those patients needs
yet only three days later the
Pennsylvania Department of Health issued
guidance mandating that nursing home
accept patients even after they had
tested positive for covet 19.
must admit nursing home orders willfully
and deliberately disregarded CDC
and CMS guidance
now Admiral Rachel Levine then
Pennsylvania Secretary of Health moved
her own mother out of a personal care
home as patients with covid-19 were
being moved in
a decision that ultimately led to more
infections and more deaths among our
state's seniors while shielding her own
family which was a luxury that was not
afforded to many pennsylvanians these
disastrous Public Health policies led to
insurmountable amount of pain and
grieving for families who lost loved
ones my office received calls from
constituents who were refused the chance
to visit dying spouses parents and
grandparents yet this committee has been
stonewalled by requests for more
information regarding these must admit
orders
it's time to have accountability it's
time to have accountability for failures
and cover-ups that led to thousands of
needless deaths
Dr Grabowski given the guidance issued
at that time in March of 2020 by CMS
was there a good rationale for the must
accept orders issued in Pennsylvania and
in other states
as I said earlier
that policy was a mistake I agree it was
an incredibly lethal mistake that was
made
Mrs is I understand your group has
members from Pennsylvania as well we do
can you please describe the end result
of these orders and the impact that they
had in my home state the Commonwealth of
Pennsylvania regardless of the state it
was
um
it devastated families even to today
because I know that Pennsylvania
Pennsylvania families New Jersey
families New York families all reach out
with an eerie story of how their loved
ones met their last days and those that
persisted in nursing homes with the
lockdown afterwards they were treated
like zoo animals you cannot see your
family except a glass store what there's
some electronic device we have
devastated our families because seniors
are the center core of our of our of our
families my mom didn't get to meet her
grandchildren or her great-grandchildren
and we're going to continue to stand for
them because they are the center of our
families and I'm sure everyone feels the
same whatever state we are in I think
that's such an important information
that you bring to us here today one of
the purposes of this select subcommittee
is to gather information to be proactive
to have that understanding when moving
forward and unfortunately we might face
another pandemic what appropriate steps
need to be taken your information and
the other panelists being present today
allow us to formulate those opinion I
thank each and every one of you for
participating here today I thank you Mr
chairman and I yield the remainder of my
time
I think I now recognize the ranking
member of the full committee Mr Raskin
for five minutes of questions thank you
kindly Mr chairman I want to extend my
sympathy to everyone here who lost
family members in this nightmare
um in the early weeks of the pandemic
Public Health experts projected that
nursing homes and long-term facilities
would be sharply hit by covid and the
federal government's lethally chaotic
response exacerbated Staffing shortages
and deprived nursing homes of protective
equipment and testing kits that they
needed president Trump pledged to quote
deploy every resource and power that we
have to protect older Americans and yet
the last Administration failed to
nationalize the supply chain and fully
utilize FEMA's capabilities to provide
adequate PPE testing and resources to
nursing homes and long-term facilities
public reporting revealed that supplies
were limited did not arrive at all or
were unusable I want to enter into the
record a CNN article titled nursing
homes received defective equipment as
part of trump Administration Supply
initiative Mr chairman
without objection thank you as a result
nursing homes were left with scant
supplies of PPE testing and other
resources necessary to protect their
residents and staff even more the Trump
Administration took steps to relax
Federal oversight and infection control
in nursing homes during the pandemic
some nursing homes left unregulated gave
hydroxychloroquine to covid positive
patients of treatment shown not to be
useful or safe for the coronavirus and
by May of 2020 residents and workers in
nursing homes and long-term care
facilities accounted for roughly 40
percent of total coveted deaths in the
United States Dr Grabowski how did the
Trump administration's failures to offer
a national testing in PPE procurement
strategy and corresponding deregulation
of the nursing home industry undercut
efforts to limit the spread of covid-19
in the nursing homes
sure the the Trump Administration pushed
out the procurement to the states which
then pushed it out to the nursing home
so nursing homes were competing with one
another for testing kits and PPE and
they were competing with hospitals and
unfortunately we put our nursing homes
with the frail as the most vulnerable
individuals in our system at the back of
the line whether they should have been
at the front of the line to get these
supplies as you noted uh later the Trump
Administration did send two weeks of
supplies but much of that was defective
I had been on TV not as much as Mrs
Dean's on TV but occasionally during
that time period people would see me on
TV talking about PPE staff started
sending me this defective PPE just to
just to show me I had this arriving to
my office at Harvard there was a
complete and utter debacle
so instead of a coordinated Nationwide
strategy the way some countries had we
had this Doggy Dog system at the lowest
levels on a race to the bottom we should
have nationalized as you said the supply
chain we use the defense production act
you'll remember for ventilators we never
use that for PPE uh uh representative
Dingle already described going to China
trying to use trash bags that that's
completely unacceptable so one of the
driving factors in the nursing home
infection and high death rates was the
surrounding Community spread of covet I
remember when some nursing homes in my
district were hit and the people there
were convinced that it was the staffers
who had been taking it essentially
inadvertently unwittingly from facility
facility
how would the unprecedented rate of
covid spread across a given Community
have a direct impact on the spread of
covid within the long-term facilities of
nursing homes yeah it both came from the
community and then as you suggested it
was staff working across facilities
there's a really elegant study that used
cell phone data and was able to track
staff moving across nursing homes and
spreading the coveted virus across those
nursing homes so when we lack PPE when
we lack testing uh there's really good
evidence to suggest covid was coming
coming from the surrounding community
and as you suggested the secret weapon
of covid was that it was asymptomatic it
was you know this was not anything these
staff did wrong they thought they were
okay we didn't have testing or PPE and
so they were they were bringing it in uh
unknowingly all right so we had no
federal strategy and I remember in
Congress we were begging for a national
strategy um and then there were all
kinds of conflicting signals sent out
about hydroxychloric when this will
disappear in April this will all go away
China is doing a great job I'm in
constant touch with China and so on what
should the Federal government have done
and what can we do next time in the
early months of a pandemic to prevent
like this rapid spread the federal
government next time needs to own the
problem from the beginning as you said
nationalize the supply chain ensure that
every Nursing Home in the country has
adequate supplies personal protective
equipment rapid testing we also need to
support the workforce far too many
nursing homes had staff shortages staff
were getting six staff left in in large
numbers we lost hundreds of thousands of
Staff this was the most dangerous job in
America it was uh there were incredibly
High death rates and so staff not
surprisingly went to work for for you
know in other parts of the economy some
have come back but not all of them so we
have a big a big shortage right now
thank you Mr chairman yield back
I think if you check the record there
were strategies in place they may not
have been perfect but there were
strategies in in place
and with that I'd like to recognize Dr
McCormick for five minutes of questions
thank you Mr chair first of all I
appreciate everybody being here today I
appreciate your heartfelt testimony
the experiences that you've had that
have made you who you are and why you're
involved
in my experience over 20 years in the
military and and finishing up as an ER
Dock and a matter of fact from the
beginning of the pandemic
I was serving as a night shift yard dock
full-time working in the ER being
exposed to fevers we didn't know where
it came from
and trying to figure out what this novel
virus would do to our patient population
and we got it wrong
I'll tell you when the novel virus hits
you or any novel disease you don't know
what to do that's a fact so we're the
healthcare professionals the people with
the scientific background the people who
understood how viruses work how they
propagate how they create inflammation
got it wrong we're going off of Old
Technologies old assumptions and I
remember we were intubating people that
probably shouldn't have been intubated
we didn't use NSAIDs we didn't use
steroids
we didn't take into account how this
virus could be different from other
viruses we knew in the past
let me tell you what else I witnessed as
an ER doctor I watched family struggle
with this once we
were no longer able to allow families
into the ER I watch people die by
themselves
I held the hands of people who were
dying
and looked in their eyes and told them I
was going to do my very best but knew
there was very little I could do because
we didn't know what to do
I I watched and prayed with people
knowing that the outcome was going to be
very poor and knowing we were doing some
things very wrong
um over time and realizing as it
continued
I became very aware that the government
was the biggest problem of all
they didn't help this pandemic they got
in the way of the conversation
they interjected themselves between the
professionals and the patients
they kept families apart they didn't let
people even die with dignity
or with any choice in their own health
care
all right let me ask you this this is my
take home is why do we keep on turning
back to the government to solve the
problems that the government created
that's what I get out of this
every step of the way the government has
biased us
and been wrong almost every step let me
let me give you some examples
Origins will we ever get to the uh when
you bias people on where the origins
came from because the government seems
to think they know where it came from
you can't actually determine if we
funded the origins of this or if it or
how it got here because we can't have an
honest conversations this is the
government get in the way vaccinations
whether they benefit you or or their
detriment to you when you politicize
something some people that should have
had it didn't get it and some people
that shouldn't have had it got it later
because the government involvement
treatments we already know the
government was weighing in on it way
before they had any clue what was good
for you and that bias medical scientists
and doctors to do the wrong thing
because government was involved patient
placement I think we've covered that
here today
travel
masks School openings business openings
censorship of Physicians who are
treating patients
because the government was supposedly
the expert instead of the Physicians
making people think this was a political
disease rather than a virus
we've traveled all over individual
rights the ability to self-determine
the ability to think on ourselves and
actually have an honest
access to information to make good
decisions rather than biased information
coming from a government that's biased
already because of what you guys already
said
lobbyists people who put money in your
pocket people who want Power
people who love the fact that they can
make decisions for you because they seem
to think that they're experts or because
they're powerful and we have to succumb
to them that we the people are subject
to a government
when you say we need to be ready for the
next one and say we need rapid testing
for what it won't be covered the next
one will be something else
the problem is we keep on thinking that
the government's going to prepare us for
the next thing we have to have a
flexible model we have to allow
scientists and doctors and hospitals to
be ready on their own to prepare them by
not overburdening them with regulation
and fees and non-reimbursements because
of special interest not allowing us to
get our Hospital Systems healthy
I don't have any questions for you
because I know you are the solution not
me
you guys have already talked about the
hurt and contamination of this
conversation because of the government
involved so I hope we have a real
conversation about where the government
shouldn't be involved
and how they actually hurt the
conversation and when we politicize any
disease and I love how sometimes my my
colleagues from the the opposite side
also we should not make this political
by the way Trump's at fault
this is not helpful conversation
let's get the government out of the way
and empower the people to deal with the
disease or whatever else problems they
have in life and with that I yield sir
foreign thank you I now recognize Ms
Ross from North Carolina for five
minutes of questions
um first I'd like to express my deepest
sympathies to all Americans who have
lost loved ones to covid-19 and and to
our Witnesses who have lost loved ones
as lawmakers we have an obligation to
ensure that seniors are protected and
cared for whether they live in nursing
homes assisted living facilities
independent housing or reside with their
families
the Biden Administration has been
working hard to fix a desperately broken
nursing home system I was a state
legislature legislator and we worked to
try to help the nursing home system as
well and um I don't know what the answer
ultimately is but it definitely has to
be investing in our seniors
prior to the pandemic government
accountability office reported that um
the nursing home industry had been
failing to maintain basic infection
control standards like hand washing or
wearing masks even before the pandemic
seniors fared no better when the
coronavirus flooded into their nursing
homes from outside communities likewise
reeling from the same failures of the
previous administration to deliver
timely or even usable PPE testing kits
and vaccines Dr Grabowski how could the
federal government have better supported
States and nursing homes early in the
pandemic
once again uh States and particular
nursing homes really struggled to
acquire personal protective equipment
really struggled to get rapid testing
there was a role there for the
government to fill that Gap once again
when you put nursing homes in a in a
market where they're competing with all
these other entities they they weren't
in the front of the line where they
should have been they were pushed to the
back of the line they ultimately ended
up getting faulty PPE there were gaps
and and sort of coverage across
facilities
it was a complete debacle so I this is
not an area when it comes to the lives
of our of our older adults that we
should just let the market work this out
we should have there was a role there
for governments to help the state and
the and and the nursing homes okay and
because of the American Rescue plan and
the most successful Vex vaccine campaign
in hit in the history of this country
the rate of deaths among nursing home
residents fell from nearly two deaths
per 100 residents in January 2021 to a
low of point 0-3 in July 2021.
um doctor in that time frame how did you
see the federal government apply lessons
learned from earlier in the pandemic to
ensure that past mistakes were not
repeated
uh absolutely there's a there's a role
for the federal government here it's
it's not sitting on the sidelines or
pushing the problem down to States and
nursing homes it's it's actually
engaging with them and uh we saw that
with the with the Mandate for example
for uh booster vaccines uh for our
workers and nursing homes that was an
incredible success and and I I think we
we've uh hopefully will continue to see
that kind of Engagement and centralized
role for for uh the administration going
forward
um and this Administration also has
expanded inspection activities and
targeted more aggressive enforcement
measures for high-risk nursing
facilities uh supported good paying
nursing home jobs and training increased
industry transparency and accountability
and for the first time in nearly 40
years the Biden Administration will soon
update federal Staffing standards to
ensure higher quality care for nursing
home residents doctor again for you how
do these steps move the ball forward on
addressing systemic problems in nursing
home care that have been ignored for far
too long yeah all three are incredibly
important let me go in reverse order the
Staffing we have far too few staff in
our in our buildings this was true
pre-pandemic has been trooped during the
pandemic Staffing is Central to good
quality nursing home care and good
quality of life we need more staff in
this sector so the minimum Staffing
standard is a great start there once
again in terms of transparency we want
to know who owns these buildings and
what they're doing with our money
those are great steps and then
regulation we need to invest in
oversight and enforcement as you said
that was uh that was declining under the
prior Administration that's actually
been been turned around here and I
actually think
um you know we need to address some of
the the gaps right now in funding for
for state survey agencies I think that's
a real area of priority going forward
okay and then just one question that
affects my home state of North Carolina
would Medicaid expansion help with
funding our nursing homes so I'm also
from North Carolina and uh so this would
help for the non-elderly but not for the
older adults so it it we have shown that
in our research that expanding Medicaid
did lead to better better long-term care
for non-non-elderly Medicaid recipients
thank you very much and I yield back
I now recognize Mr Cuda from Hawaii for
five minutes of questions
thank you very much Mr chair you know
living in a nursing home during the
pandemic became a death sentence for
approximately 176 000 Americans and
today nursing home staff continued to
have one of the most dangerous jobs in
our country according to the CDC there
are 15 600 Medicare and Medicaid
certified nursing homes and 1.7 million
beds providing care to our constituents
in every District across our country Dr
Grabowski we know nursing home residents
and workers were a vulnerable population
during the covid-19 pandemic now three
years later would you say they are more
or less vulnerable if faced with
evolving or new rapidly spreading
viruses
you know I I think we're in much better
shape relative to covid but moving
forward as as new pandemics occur we
need to apply the lessons that we've all
been talking about here and apply good
policy going forward I do think we have
Staffing shortages in some of our
buildings and that's going to be an
issue going forward we really need to
fortify the workforce
thank you and in building on that you
know and definitely Staffing shortages
is a severe crisis right now our Public
Health infrastructure is facing if there
is one critical lesson we've learned
from covid-19 it is the importance of
sustained and adequate investments in
programs that ensure the health and
safety of our nation's nursing home and
long-term care residents from resources
for adequate Staffing as we just talked
about to oversight and monitoring yet as
we're having this hearing House
Republicans continue to hold America's
full faith and credit hostage so that
they can push Draconian cuts to crucial
Federal programs meant to protect
nursing home residents from harm for
example Republicans default on America
Act contains a 22 percent cut to the
centers for Medicare and Medicaid
services state survey and certification
program cms's survey and certification
efforts help the agency determine
whether nursing homes and other
providers are meeting basic quality and
safety levels and whether to pursue any
remedies as a result of the pandemic
about a third of all nursing homes are
overdue for an inspection at the start
of this Year many had last reported
inspections prior to the pandemic and
now under Republican budget proposal
Cuts this backlog would be compounded
with CMS unable to complete 38 percent
of required home and safety
recertification surveys for nursing
homes and Home Health agencies leaving
1.4 million seniors at greater risk of
dangerous and unsanitary conditions Dr
Grabowski what happens to Federal
oversight over nursing home operations
and quality of care if funding is cut by
22 percent are we able to ensure that
nursing home residents are adequately
protected from threats to their health
that would be an absolute disaster I was
part of once again a national academies
committee we recommended increasing
funding this was at Baseline and now
this is talking about going in the other
direction uh once again these are frail
older adults many with Alzheimer's and
Dementia they're not able in many
instances to monitor their own care
there's a real role for surveying
certification to come in and ensure uh
that that all care requirements are
being met
these vulnerable Americans need
Advocates they need family members to be
able to share their concerns have their
concerns address you know in addition to
cutting funding for CMS Republicans
default on America Act would also impose
a 22 percent cut on the administration
for Community living's long-term care
Ombudsman program the long-term care
ombudsman's work is to identify
investigate and resolve complaints made
by or on behalf of nursing home
residents Dr krabalski tragic things
happen when people don't have an
advocate a way to raise concerns to take
actions we've heard those heartbreaking
stories right here in this room today
what will happen if we cut Ombudsman
funding reducing the resources dedicated
to investigating residents concerns
about their treatment and their safety
with these horrific Cuts as proposed by
House Republicans Dumas to repeat these
fatal mistakes of the past when the
Ombudsman program is properly funded
it's it's incredibly uh successful once
again that National academies committee
that I served on WE recommended
increasing funding and making sure that
the Ombudsman program was working well
across the country once again some areas
that's working really well other areas
it needs further support we don't want
to make Cuts that's once again that's
going in the wrong direction absolutely
no Cuts let's learn from the mistakes of
the past the reality is again when we
were looking at the pandemic American
deaths one in ten of all covid-19 deaths
in America was linked to a nursing home
at the height of our pandemic one in
every 50 nursing home residents died of
covid 19. no more cut stop these
Draconian threats on our people and
let's learn from those lessons past
thank you Dr govowski I yield back my
time
thank you I now recognize the ranking
member
um for the purpose of a closing
statement
thank you Mr chairman in all that we do
as members of this select subcommittee
our Focus must remain on preventing harm
and saving lives in the event of a
future Public Health threat
and as we look ahead to the Future and
work to craft policies that prevent
future loss of life there are lessons we
must learn from our covid-19 response as
I mentioned at the start of this hearing
we lost two hundred thousand residents
and staff of long-term care facilities
across the country to this pandemic 200
000 of our fellow Americans perished due
to covet 19. and while at the time we
knew little about this deadly novel
Airborne virus and while at the time we
lacked access to vaccines testing and
Therapeutics we now have the
responsibility to take the resources
tools and knowledge we have gained over
the last three years to create better
policies that protect our health in the
future policies that prioritize
compassion and Center our attention on
defending our most vulnerable
populations especially the elderly who
were and are at highest risk of severe
illness
hospitalizations and death from cover
19. this work must include promoting
transparency strengthening protections
and standards in nursing homes and
correcting course on the failed policies
under the Trump Administration that left
seniors more vulnerable to infection
severe illnesses and debt to cover 19. I
hope that these guiding principles can
serve as a model for our work in this
subcommittee and while in many ways with
the Biden Administration we have already
taken steps toward this goal by
reinstating reinforcing Federal nursing
home standards
improving inspections and strengthening
our health care Workforce there is much
more work to be done
and now we must continue on this path
not reverse course with harmful budget
cuts that harm our seniors health
so I hope at the end of the day we have
moved the ball forward that together we
can put people over politics save lives
and right the wrongs that cause so much
suffering in this pandemic
thank you
thank you as I have stated many many
times the goal of this Select Committee
is to have a better path forward
to admit to our mistakes
to learn from our mistakes to correct
our mistakes
and to provide accountability for any
mistakes that were made especially if
mistakes were made
because of political motives or personal
motives
decisions can be made on data and
sometimes there was no data as everyone
has pointed out
but sometimes decisions were made in
spite of the data
what were the motives were they
political were they personal
with covid many lessons have been
learned our eyes have been to open to
too many things
shamefully
for our nation
that we had so many deficiencies
we talk about PPE
we talk about medications themselves
our supply chain
is reliant on China and other countries
we are not an independent nation
when it comes to our supply chain
especially in medicine
look at your generic medications
look at our protective equipment if
you'd have told me when I was in Iraq
that my protective equipment and my
Pharmaceuticals as a surgeon there
relied on China an adversary how did we
get here
this is not any one Administration
we have done this to ourselves
over the last 50 or 60 years
you know we've we've learned that not
everyone was adhering to standards
even pre-covered
but covet opened our eyes to a lot of
things
but in some places standards were being
adhered to
and it was mentioned Community rates
matter they do matter
that was an important piece of data for
all of us
in many communities if the community
rate was high it was high in the nursing
homes
is that the only Factor
or was it the fact that maybe some
nursing homes weren't adhering to
guidelines
you know we have areas where it may have
a high rate in the community but a lower
rate in the nursing homes
and if so why was that Miss lesko
brought that up the difference between
Arizona and New York
where many of the vulnerable people in
America happen to live in Arizona
through this time we've looked at
Community rates versus in-school rates
you were safer in school
than you were at the grocery store
or better yet at the liquor store
which was open
yet we kept schools closed or some did
I look at early on some of the things
that we saw and learned that one size
does not fit all
you know we we had a legitimate fear and
we said let's go to lockdowns I get that
but when you keep them up and you tell
people not to go to the doctor
that's a problem
those were decisions that were made as
well
actually had a sheriff in one of my
rural counties called me and said I just
want you to know had a guy 71 years old
he was scheduled to have his painful
hernia repaired they called him and
canceled it
and he took his own life because he was
in so much pain
there were no cases in that county at
the time
one size does not fit all
one size fits all can be very dangerous
when I look at covid I look at as
something that should have United this
nation and instead it divided us
and why
because it was a presidential political
year
that's my opinion
it divided us politics took over
we see political organizations having
influence on CDC guidelines
that should not be the case
medicine doesn't deserve that
I see even on this committee
gratitude for vaccines and the vaccine
delivery and I give credit to the
vaccine delivery
that was an impressive impressive
maneuver
largely provided by our military as far
as actual delivery
but I don't hear anybody who's you know
talking about that
from this side
giving kudos to operation warp speed
itself
there were mistakes from both sides of
the aisle from Every Avenue here
get the politics out of it
we see mandates coming from a politician
saying You must get the vaccine I'm
pro-vaccine
but I'm not
in a position to say that there may not
be some adverse effects for some people
and that some people might have
questions a mandate that says you get
this or you lose your job and there's no
conversation with a physician
what are we doing
I heard time and time again from
patients who said
when I talk to you Dr wenstrup I'm more
likely to get the vaccine
but when I'm being told
I have to get it
by a politician that's a problem I just
want to be educated
not indoctrinated
there's a huge mistake that we have made
in this country
I don't know if any of you have noticed
throughout your life but Americans don't
do well with because I told you so
it doesn't work in America
listen I want to thank Those Who
provided testimony for today's hearing I
know it's very personal
and I think it hurts all of us and I
think across both sides of the aisle
that pain is felt
and I want to share with you publicly
you know that we were going to try to
relieve the pain in any way that we can
going forward
it's hard to comprehend how as a society
States implemented mandates that
resulted in loved ones dying alone
without a single family member there
able to say goodbye
it's hard
this hearing and the testimony provided
today from those directly affected by
the deadly orders enacted in New York
New Jersey and Pennsylvania is essential
to have as we move forward in our
investigation into the nursing home
policies enacted by state officials
and the cover-up that ensued
these orders were more than a mistake
they were a deadly decision
they were medical malpractice
by people that don't have a medical
degree
or a license to practice medicine
I think that we can agree that vaccines
were extremely helpful to protect our
elderly and nursing homes
but this hearing and this investigation
is about the decisions made prior to the
development of the vaccine and what
actions were taken to avoid culpability
for the deaths of thousands of Americans
today we heard important testimony that
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo loved to
blame politics at every opportunity
and then he turned to attacks
belittlement and name-calling when
challenged
he didn't meet with the victims of
families or show sympathy to those who
were hurting instead he wrote a book
Governor Cuomo had resources at his
disposal to protect the vulnerable and
he failed to use them the comfort and
the Javits Center
sat virtually empty
the orders from New York prohibited
testing of incoming patients for kova
19. they mandated that nursing homes and
long-term care facilities accept coveted
positive patients this was directly
against the CDC Guidance the CMS
guidance
and frankly common sense
the least common medical sense
in New York over ten thousand nursing
home deaths occurred in the 50 days
before Governor Cuomo's mandate was
rescinded
today we heard concerning testimony
regarding the manipulation of data from
Governor kuono's own office
the Biden Department of Justice chose
not to investigate the state orders
nor the ensuing cover-up
we will
today we're able to have bipartisan
agreement
that seniors were failed
and too many died
While others blame the Trump
Administration the fact is these deadly
nursing home policies were not
implemented Nationwide instead they were
developed and enacted by states with
with honestly Democrat Governors New
York New Jersey and Pennsylvania and
against the guidance provided by the
Trump Administration from CMS and CDC
and that's the key not the
administration
but the CMS and CDC
which should be agnostic of politics
those who are responsible for these
mandates must be held accountable
the victims and their families deserve
transparency
and to know who created these must admit
orders
and they deserve the opportunity to hold
them accountable
we cannot simply just blame one or the
other and move on
when families are missing their loved
ones
and missing the closure
that comes with accountability
the select subcommittee on the
coronavirus pandemic will continue to
examine the deadly policy decisions
surrounding nursing homes and we will
continue to investigate the failed
leadership of State officials during the
covid-19 pandemic and we will continue
to provide as best we can a path forward
for America
it is much better for America
and has accountability and science
behind it
I don't know
and without objection all members will
have five legislative days within which
to submit materials and to submit
additional written questions for the
witnesses which will be forwarded to the
witnesses for their response and with
this with that
this hearing is adjourned thank you
everyone
foreign